σίγουρα δεν θέλουμε να έχουμε πενήντασυλόγους δεν χωρούσε αλλά το ναμπει ένας νέος σύλλογος που
θα πιστεύουμε σίγουρος ότι θα βοηθήσω και τους υπόλιπους συλόγους να εξιχρονιστούμε να αλλάξουμε το
έχουμε να ανάγκι πολλ παιδιά χάνονται γιατί όλοι έχουν ον νήρο να γίνουν ποτοσφεριστές πολλά
παιδα κια στις ακατημίες του ποδοσφέρού παραίθεση έχει πάνω από διακό αράντα ακατήμις το ποτόσερο
για μια χώρα που μαστε λιόν κάτω που ένανακατομυριώ καταλαβαίνεις πόσα παιδά κια είναι πάρα
πολύ γρήγορα πο θα μπορούσαν να πειδήσουν πολύ μακριά ή πολύ ψηλά αλλά νομίζομον ότι
έτσι όπως ταφέρνουσε ότι να ντοποδόερο πρέπει με κάποιον τρόπο να να έρθουν στον κατάληλο
χώρο αν κάνουν για των κλαστικό ναθίσμο επειδή κατάτιδική μου γνώμη ο κλατικός αθηθνισμούς δεν
έχει αδικεία δε ξεκρινιούτε οκριτής ούτεθα σε βάλο πρόπουμε της να παέξεις υπάρχει η μεζούρα
και το χρονό μετρο που αμ αγράψει δην πουρικανές να σαφισβητήσει κλίνοντας κύρια ποσμετά ποτ
σε όλι ιάδς και άλες τόρις επιτυχίς τι συμβουλεύει τανα παίδια αυτό που συμβουλεύω είναι
τίποτα δε σου χαρίζεται μην περιμένει έκανες ια εφάνι συγκαλήι έκνε σε ένα καλό χρόνον
έκανε σε ένα καλόν άλμα ότι που κμετ γα να αρτουνούλα οποσθέρις μόνο δουλειά δουλειά
δουλειά και επίστης το είναι αυτόν τους οι ιδύος εκεί που τα πράγματα εμπακαλά γιατί
όταν παν καλά τα πράγματα και σε πο αντιαφέρει όταν δεν πά κατά τα πράγματα
να υπάρχει πίστι δουλειά προπόνησι σε βασμό στο χώρο και αν είναι να έρτει το
ποτέλεσμα ναένθασαδικής ιχανέναας υρ ποτοχαριστό πολίαεσυζήσεις εγώ ευχασες αλλάνα σε καλφιλές και φίλι άλονατααλάότφθασε στο
τέλος του τα λέμε τιν επχούμε να εδομάλο